hey it's memphis from big brother
all-stars and this is my e.t
post-eviction interview by a vote
of two to zero memphis
you are evicted from the big brother
house
good luck you guys you're gonna need it
i think the vote that stung the most
would probably have to be
enzo's and the reason why is
i think he really really wanted to keep
me in the house but he was
definitely wanting to keep cody happy so
he was definitely playing the game for
cody and you could really see that so i
thought he was
true in his statement of wanting to keep
me so i think that that made it
that made it worse
when i said good luck you're going to
need it i was referring to cody i think
ultimately i think i was a safer bet to
stay in the house over christmas because
i was going to take him and enzo to the
final three
so at least i would have kept him safe
next week
i think my game went wrong with
obviously trusting enzo
i think uh i probably if i would have
changed one part of the game i probably
would have vetted enzo out a little bit
better
and just uh to see if i could trust him
because obviously i could
i think the house guest left doing the
worst of jury management it's probably
enzo i mean enzo's so light-hearted and
just whatever
and anything goes and i think him
fluttering and not telling people the
truth like when they're leaving the
house and they're asking for votes and
stuff like that
i think he's gonna come back and bite
him if he ends up in the final two
the juror that i'm least looking forward
to seeing
is none of them i have no problems with
any of them
and i look forward to spending the next
you know week or so
hanging out with them and and just
kicking back outside
of the crazy big brother house
any women you are maybe hoping to see in
there
oh man let's see what happens let's see
who we end up with see who's
see who's in that house you know if
christmas decides to like show her
face in that in that house it might be
uh you know someone that i could uh at
least have a good conversation with
well first of all to entertain a
showmance you know that question was
pushed on me pretty hardcore before i
came in and i was very
adamant about not having a showmance
that i have a beautiful amazing woman at
home
but i wanted to throw out one name for
you guys and it was christmas and it was
funny because i didn't know she was
going in the house
at all and i thought it was pretty
ironic
when she showed up um but again
i had never met christmas before so i
was going after zero
off of nothing basically but besides her
show so
me and christmas have a great
relationship we're very similar we're
both sagittarius we both have young boys
um so i have a great rapport with her
and i'm sure we'll be friends for a
really long time you